you know when you forget celebrity I am
now in this world I've got access to our
business I guess so she wouldn't have
known she couldn't do better when she's
already in that world
I mean why she knows that now but she
probably thoughts on her so she probably
thought it's better today why did they
why did they split up because he cheated
well I don't know why no them too
because he cheated and that's why she
left him full so not because she wanted
half of his food but she's incentivized
too she became the richest woman in the
world but wait guys one at a time Auntie
will go ahead he cheated did they say
that he was cheating
he stepped out as you know maybe she
weren't giving him no six
you could have forgiven him talk about
it look how long they've been together
they've been together but you were
saying that if
all then so if she stayed with him after
he cheated would she not be stupid and
look what she done and look what she
done made more of a fool of herself she
might as well stay there